hello and welcome to another edition of
modeling the masters my name is Evan
Carmichael and today we're going to be
talking about the famous entrepreneur
Walt Disney and how you can model his
strategies to achieve success with your
business
everyone knows Walt Disney for his
movies theme parks and cast of
characters what most people don't know
is when he first started out he had no
money he had to live in his office
because he couldn't afford write for an
apartment and he survived on a diet of
cold beans because he couldn't afford
food by committing to his business and
sticking with it he was now able to
build a business that has almost 40
billion dollars in revenue so today
we're going to look at three lessons
that you can learn for wealth is in
success and apply it into your company
lesson number one is find something that
you love Walt Disney grew up in the
early 1900's on a farm in Missouri and
developed the passion for drawing so
much so that one of his neighbors
actually paid him to draw some cartoons
of his horses when Walt Disney got to
school he found that he was a good
student but he really enjoyed doodling
as opposed to paying attention to his
teachers he connected with one of his
high school papers and started drawing
patriotic cartoons for the school paper
when he was 16 though he found that
school just wasn't for him so he dropped
out join the Red Cross learn to become
an ambulance driver and actually was
shipped to France to become an ambulance
driver over there he couldn't lose that
passion for drawing and cartooning and
he ended up plastering his ambulance
full of different cartoon creations that
he had made people knew him on the
street because he was the ambulance
driver with all the different cartoons
blasted on his ambulance
he decided that cartooning was for him
he was going to be an artist and return
to America to start his career as an
artist so lesson number one really is
make sure you have that strong passion
for your business if you don't really
love it it's going to be hard to succeed
as a business owner if you look at any
famous entrepreneur and why they serve
the business it wasn't for the money
money comes when you're really
passionate about what you're doing so
think about what is it that you do in
your spare time what do you really enjoy
doing what gets you going in the morning
what are your hobbies and how can you
turn those into a potential business
opportunity lesson number two is push
the boundaries Walt Disney first made
his mark in 1934 when he proposed making
a feature-length animation which had
never been done before it was called
Snow White
took three years to make he went a
hundred percent over budget people
thought he was crazy for doing it you
ran out of money at the end and had to
actually act out the last scenes of the
movie for his bankers to get the money
he needed to close and finish the movie
it ended up being a huge success it was
the biggest hit of the year he won an
Academy Award for it and it was a
financial gain for him Walt Disney's
next big project was Disneyland a 338
year project out in California a theme
park which had nothing to do with his
movies people thought he was crazy again
why would you do this what tie does it
have to your movie business but he had a
vision he was determined to make it
happen and again it was a big success
for him then he went on to open up the
Walt Disney World in Florida and the
company was able to open up different
theme parks around the world so the
message for entrepreneurs here is push
the boundaries you need to do something
different to get your company noticed as
a small entrepreneur there's so much
competition it's so difficult to get on
people's radar screens and make them pay
attention to you so you have to do
something that's going to get your
notice something that will help you
stand out from the crowd so what is it
that will be your equivalent of a Snow
White something that's never been done
before it's really going to get you
notice and get the attention paid to
your business lesson number three is
stay top of mind Walt Disney did
everything he could to make sure people
kept remembering the Walt Disney name he
did a lot of advertising as an example
so we did TV campaigns direct mail
campaigns print ads he even did grocery
store coupon cutout so when you're at
the grocery store you're thinking about
Walt Disney he was also a pioneer in
merchandising so whenever a new feature
film came out that was a Walt Disney
production you would also be able to buy
all the merchandise that went along with
it today while Disney is known not only
for its movies but its TV stations theme
parks dolls toys games and a whole host
of other merchandise so the lesson for
entrepreneurs is stay top of mind you
need to do whatever you can to make sure
your customers are always thinking about
you the easiest way to grow a business
is to sell more to your existing
customers the hardest way to grow a
business is to go and try to find new
so do whatever you can to make sure your
customers are always thinking about you
you're the first person that comes to
mind when you're thinking about your
product or service and it's the best way
to be able to grow your business Walt
Disney is an entrepreneurial legend
who's built up one of the most
recognized companies in the world but
remember when he first got started he
had no money nobody believed in him he
had to live out of his office because he
couldn't afford an apartment and he
survived on a diet of cold beans because
he couldn't afford other food by
following his lessons though you too can
achieve entrepreneurial success so
remember find something you love push
the boundaries and stay top of mind I
hope you've enjoyed this episode of
modeling the Masters to learn more about
Walt Disney and his entrepreneurial
success you can visit our website at
Evan Carmichael com and you can also
check out our blog which is listed below
I also want to take this opportunity to
thank Fanta media for the great work
they've done in producing this video and
I hope you'll join us for the next
episode of modeling the Masters
you